Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson  are more in love than ever I want to  keep that up the 33 year old reality  star and the 26 year old NBA pro are  about to be parents to their first child  together and a source tells ET the  couple is solid and the pregnancy has  brought them closer together he makes it  more like five while the source says  that there are no immediate plans for a  wedding it's not totally off the table  quote right now it's just all about the  new baby they're not rushing to get  married but they're in it for the long  haul for sure she's a romantic she would  definitely get married again I'm in a  good healthy relationship as for where  the pair will live when their bundle of  joy arrives  we're told Khloe and Tristan will be  bicoastal and spend very little time  apart they're going to be very hands-on  parents they'll be great  they're very prepared I feel great and I  feel so lucky to feel so great  [Music]